foreign
[Music]
for some of you it probably seemed like
this day would never come
maybe you're even wondering if you're
ready for this
[Music]
for what comes next
you have no idea what I'm capable of
I didn't know who he was
I don't fight France because I would win
never apologize for saving lives there's
only one way this kid goes back out
there and that's on a very short leash
I'm just happy helping people
people try to kill us every single day
right
how old are you
train more and complained less we could
get back to saving lives
make them pay for what he did to your
world welcome son of he who slayed my
husband I am a normal human superhero I
wish he was dead too but not for your
sake kill fast and ask questions later
oh yeah
feltramide against viltromite that has
not happened since the Great Purge
[Music]
you should have died at Birth